hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the great sources of anxiety for
many adults even those who are in a
situation of relative affluence and it's
also a worry for many children who are
you know concerned with these these
sorts of things in terms of you know
their situation of their parents is this
question what am I going to do how am I
going to get by
how will I put food on the table how
will I keep a roof over our head and
many people are in situations where this
you know does seem to them to be
something that they want to be worried
about in part because they are in fact
in a situation of what we call
insecurity the question that Epictetus
wants us to grapple with and he's going
to give us a very good discussion of
this in chapter 26 of book 3 is whether
this insecurity want to be a source of
anxiety agony oh there's a whole video
on that by the way if you know what or
fear for us or whether we should
approach these matters with a kind of
confidence and he's not going to just
say hey buck up you know don't worry
about it keep it out of your mind he's
doing something very helpful for us in
this chapter which is leading the person
who is concerned with these things
through a reasoning process so that they
can reflect and see that these fears are
actually irrational but they don't have
to be so concerned about the possibility
of starvation or poverty or illness why
not well as it turns out this is where
he's going to be particularly helpful I
think he's going to show us that the
fears that we think are what are really
bothering us are the surface level and
then if we probe a little bit we see
that we have other fears that are coming
to light which are equally irrational
and those are providing the basis for
this expression of this fear so he
starts out by talking about this state
of Maria Appa Maria and
could mean you know being stuck yeah a
path and you can't find your way through
anymore like when you go into the forest
and path ends now you like where we go
right you agree trace your path but you
can't get through it can also mean a
sort of puzzlement a situation where you
can't figure things out when we talk
about Plato's operatic dialogues as
being the ones where they start out
trying to figure out what virtue is and
they don't rhyme it an answer that's
them kind of authorial but it can also
mean a lack of resources in a situation
where one doesn't have what one needs
and it's also connected with this notion
of India in Greek another way of
translating that to be stuck in in want
or need and necessity but they're all
circling around this issue how am I
going to get by and so I mean epictetus
says think about other other people's
cases think about a runaway slave when
they leave their masters don't they
steal a little bit to last them for the
first few days then afterwards drift
along land and sea can try to want to
scheme after another to keep themselves
fed and what runaway slave ever died of
hunger but Europe you're not in that
situation you would actually have
resources you have an income you have
property you have this and that and then
you're worried about starving these
people don't start he talks about
beggars as well and it says you know you
see a lot of old beggars don't you how
do they live into such an old age if
they're you know constantly exposed to
the kinds of dangers that you're
imagining to be the case and he says you
tremble in line awake at night for fear
the necessities of life will fail you he
says wretch are you so blind and do you
fail to see the road to which the lack
necessities of life leads where is it
well that's death and for the Stoics
death is not something that we want to
regard as terrible I mean there are
going to be situations in which you know
once we get stuck in them that's the way
it's going to end and we don't
necessarily control whether that's going
to happen
what we do control is how we think about
it and how we react to it do we die as
somebody who you know it's constantly
worried about the the oncoming em or do
we approach it with the kind of
confidence and serenity he goes on and
he says you know what you're really
worried about is not that sort of thing
what you're really worried about is the
fear behind this fear that's the way I'm
calling it that's not his own words
which is social disgrace and he's using
this term to ice crone we contrast that
to Talk alone meaning the beautiful of
the fine or the noble twice Crone means
something like the disgraceful the
shameful the ugly and uses it in a
number of different comments you know so
he's using in a non verba adjective but
he's harsh quite a bit about this and he
says this is why you're really worried
about you're not so worried about
starving you're worried about what other
people are going to think of you by the
fact that you have to go out and find
some other way to make a living to put
food on the table he says here we go
can't you draw water or write or a sport
boys to and from school or be another's
doorkeeper these are seen as somewhat
menial professions in his own context to
drop water that's something that clamp
is one of the rulers the skull arc the
second school art of the school used to
do that was his day job and then at
night he would go to epictetus is very
coated on Xena a school and study so if
it was good enough for clay antes the
ruler of his school why is it such a
hardship for us in even think about st.
Paul and in Christian terms and the fact
that he was a tentmaker that was not a
particularly you know high class
position that was you know you're
working with your hands and mending
tents and during that's worth
you can be a stoic as a cook you don't
need to be the executive chef you can
just you know be the cook or the
dishwasher and you can get bought
you can babysit you know when he's
talking about escorting boys to and from
school
that's like wooden ante guns or where
somebody eat along those lines being in
doorkeeper and then he says this is what
the person would say it's disgraceful to
come to such a necessity now here's
where it gets very interesting we should
ask ourselves well why is that
disgraceful
is it disgraceful in and of itself well
then why are those other people doing it
why are you allowing somebody to be your
doorkeeper if it's such a disgraceful
thing this is disgraceful just for you
because you at one time were higher than
that that's where the real fear lies and
having other people say wow that guy
used to be somebody and now he's just
like the rest of us or he's nobody this
is a great fear that that people
actually feel and epictetus is going to
say is that really something disgraceful
to the science start delivering pizzas
or to start babysitting or to you know
have to cold call clients or any of
these sorts of things that are part of
the fabric of so many other people's
lives to take imagine taking a position
as a janitor in a cleaning service is
that it is that so terrible if it brings
in an income and allows you to meet the
necessities that you have so he says
what we do need to do is think about
what really is disgraceful he says is
anything disgraceful to you which is not
your own doing for which you are not
responsible which has befallen you
accidentally like a headache or a fever
is it disgraceful for you to get sick to
have the flu get a cold no you call in
sick I'm sick today the boss doesn't say
Oh shame shame how far you would follow
right they just give you a sick day he
says if your parents were poor or if
they were rich but
others as their ears and as they gave
you no help though they are living is
this disgraceful to you you might say
well look other people are going to look
at and they're going to say your parents
didn't help you there must be something
wrong with you happiness would say
that's up to them you don't control
their misinterpretations of the
situation you control how you understand
and regard the situation if you didn't
have any role in it there is nothing
disgraceful about the situation for you
he says and you never heard that the
disgraceful thing is censurable or
criticizing and the censurable is that
which deserves century and whom do you
censure for what is that his own doing
which he didn't produce himself
well did you produce the situation did
you make your father what he is or is it
in your power to reform him so epic CEO
says shouldn't you wish them for what is
not that should you wish for what has
not given you or to be ashamed when you
fail to get it why are you studying
philosophy that the whole point of
studying study philosophy so that we can
learn to distinguish what actually is
our responsibility what's in our power
what we have control over and then whole
host of things that sure other people
care about and we find ourselves tempted
to give a lot of care to both it isn't
our business at all and so if we can
look at things in the proper light we're
going to realize that that fear about
what what are people going to think is
an irrational fear and the worry about
how am I going to get by really
translates in many cases to what are
people going to think of me if I have to
take that dishwashing job or if I have
to quit school or if I have to trade in
the car for you know some older car that
isn't going to cost so much all these
sorts of things another fear that he
talks about as behind this is one that
some other people face and this is what
he actually has some very funny things
to say about
this is you fear hunger as you can see
but it's not hunger you fear but you're
afraid you will not have a professional
cook you will not have us another
servant to buy the delicacies another to
put on your shoes for you another to
dress you others to give you your
massage others to follow at your heels
in order that when you have undressed in
a bath and stretched yourself out like
men who've been crucified you may be
massaged on this side of that and that
then the masseur may stand over you and
say move over give me his side you take
his head he on your shoulder and then
when you've left the bathroom gone home
that you may shout out is no one
bringing me something to eat
and after that clear away the tables
wipe them off with a sponge what you are
afraid of is this he says that you may
not be able to live the life of the
invalid the life of luxury is actually a
life of an infant it's somebody who
needs other people to take care of all
their things and this could Ruth be real
here I mean if you think about the fact
that we use money as an exchange to give
us all the things that we need and you
know we buy goods and services from
people once we start making our way up
into you know higher income having more
properties stuff like that it becomes
very easy to start indulging ourselves
in all sorts of things or we pay other
people to do these things for us and
then we can become dependent upon them
or at least think of ourselves dependent
upon them and worry very much about if
what what I think it's taken away what
if I don't get the Christmas bonus this
year and I don't have enough to cover
all of these presents that I'm going to
buy and also pay for this and this and
this and this and this which I need
Epictetus would say those are
necessities you don't need that much in
order to live and live well so how can
we look at these matters he actually
gives us two pieces of practical advice
besides the analysis that he's carried
out of here thinking what are you really
afraid of
is that a rational thing to be afraid of
he talks in religious terms of a God
providing us what we need now this
doesn't mean that you know if you're
cynic and you're in your apartment
somewhere that you know you pray to God
and suddenly the medicine comes floating
down from heaven or things like that I
mean you could still die but the
question is what is what is what are we
provided we are provided with our
rational faculty and our Faculty of
choice which we determine how we're
going to use how do we face our
situations things are not as bad as we
tended to see them when we start
worrying about this sort of thing we
have the resources that we need in order
to meet the the challenges that face us
the other thing that he says is that we
should live like a healthy person here
he talks about living he's speaking from
experience by the way like like workers
people who have to actually work with
their hands and genuine philosophers
here he's thinking about somebody like
clay at these he also talks about living
like slaves he doesn't mean that we
should try to find somebody else to rule
over us he means that we can live and
live well without having to worry about
lots and lots of possessions lots and
lots of things that fall out of our
control we can in fact live the way that
that you know the stoic sages did the
way that Hercules did the way that
Odysseus he talks about all these
different people that is a possibility
for us but it's one that we actually
have to choose and if we do choose it
and follow throughout it we're not going
to be plagued by these irrational fears